citizens of the reject nation we have got
ourselves an official trailer for the secret
invasion i'm excited to check this out johnny tell
us how you're feeling i'm not the real johnny oh
my god i fooled ya he's edge how are you i'm the
real andrew i think or am i i've created a monster
this bit has not gone over as hilarious as
we were hoping today ladies and gentlemen
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
also a citizen king t-shirt right now available
at shopzeroedition.com if you want to pick
yourself up one today any let's get to it
i
it's a close encounter yeah yeah exactly
for years you've been avoiding earth
i have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty content
to let those calls go straight to voicemail
maria hill back yeah well this is different
how long has he been gone for how much
you know about your security detail
what do you mean how much do i know about roadie
ross nice
we're going to be very careful yeah tell us
wowee oh
that lies before us
this is just the beginning this is my war alone
and i'm the last person standing between them
and what they really
this want great and what is that
a little title cool logo where's the comedy
marvel i wasn't laughing that much about the
comments not mcu if you're not laughing it
just it seems a little off to me that was
a great trailer that that had your favorite
movies winter soldier yeah i was thinking that
the espionage it has a real thriller espionage
mystery vibe to it that paranoia that fraught
tension of like who's who what's really going
on in this world and there's so much mystery
to unpack and honestly there's this part of
me that just felt really happy for one of the
highest paid actors in the world samuel l jackson
to finally be getting like his le is like uh it's
the one he's leading he's he's leading this one
and nick fury's always been supportive you know
secret invasion of course he would be but i'm
excited to see him like really get a chance to
to showcase those dramatic acting chops again
and it looks like so gripping as much as it's a
you know invasion of body snatchers kind of vibe
in a sense right it still has uh a more of
like a grounded approach to it which i was
really really enjoying and not just samuel l
jackson but as john pointed out the maria hill
oh yeah yeah their rapport together
i'm really excited to see like the more
they bring her in and things and and the more
we get you know further past you know the little
appearances before i feel like we're gonna get to
see some intense badass maria hill more and more
but uh yeah this looked like the perfect blend
of a invasion of the body snatchers and i just
kept getting i know like winter soldier espionage
but like i was really getting a james bond kind
of vibe off this trailer in particular which i
thought was really fun and yeah like with sam
jackson you're going to get to see him probably
do both you know the scroll version and the self
version so not only do you have the samuel jackson
dramatic chops but i gotta imagine it's gonna be
fun to see him do two different iterations of
the character and like olivia coleman in here too
is like a top-notch talent and i think she's
supposed to be some kind of old ally of nick
fury's and so i'm really excited to see what their
report like there's so many like the the concept
is super intriguing but also the cast is just
dynamite and i cannot wait to see all these people
play off each other every rod like ah like ah this
is very exciting yeah i agree with you guys it's
definitely getting that winter soldier vibe and
that was really interesting that james bond uh
aspect that you threw in there but yeah this looks
really cool and i definitely love the rapport
that you mentioned between maria hill and samuel
jackson they've got such good on-screen chemistry
and their interactions are really seamless so i
love that and i love that we got ben mendelsohn
back to talos i already love to in this teaser
like we're already playing the game wait who's
that that scrolls out of scroll obviously we know
that talos has been some of the other characters
but i think the thing i'm looking most forward to
is when i watch this the second third or fourth
time when you get those little unique hints when
you see like who's revealed this squirrel is like
okay that was interesting they did point that
there were little uh hints and details there
that pointed out that might have been a scroll or
not so i'm looking forward to that obviously this
this storyline in the comics is a very epic
storyline so i like how you mentioned that
it is grounded so i'm really curious to see how
they're going to get that more grounded more like
you know it's not going to be as epic as the the
comic book story line was but i am really looking
forward to the fact that samuel jackson finally
gets to lead a series because he's one of my
favorite actors of all time so yeah i'm really
looking forward to that and uh it was awesome
seeing everett ross back freaking love martin
freeman so good as everett ross so yeah this looks
really exciting and yeah it looks great i gave
you two white [__] a chance to shout out rhodey
i gave you two watches in this show rudy was great
we'll have him in the show he's probably gonna set
he's going to have a better story to tell than
he did in the vendors age of ultron and also we
got our fa and we got our favorite sarah connor
in here emilia clark yeah yeah i don't know much
about who work that's the thing is like there's so
much that we don't really know about this because
like in the comic they they had so much more fun
with in the comic of heroes and some of them are
scrolls and i don't think we're going to go like
that big of course here and especially to keep
or or maybe it could be like a crazy cameo galore
where you know you get all kinds of people to come
back just to be able to play like a scroll version
of themself which would be a ton of fun to do
i just don't feel like we're going to
be getting that and i also feel like
with nick fury with their and perhaps maria
hell as well we could perhaps see like some
actual kind of character arc with them because you
have nick fury here when it's not exactly clear
how long he's been off of earth you know like
don cheadle was talking an interview not long ago
about like very very recent where he was saying
that with secret invasion you know the we saw them
introduced in the 90s with captain marvel and
they've sort of been percolating ever since so
there's could be people here that would had
no idea this whole time they were a scroll
and it seems like there's such a weary toll
that has been taken on nick fury over time and
whatever that passage is i'm excited to explore
what that is with his character and i i didn't
think that this trailer that that's what i would
end up be the most anticipatory towards is samuel
jackson getting a chance to really do something
refreshing with a character he's been playing
in in small roles small like little bite-sized
chunks other than like avengers and winter soldier
he gets a chance to really lead this time yeah and
then reminds you how good of a dramatic actor he
actually is beyond the meme and beyond the fun
of like oh he's showing up and being sam jackson
yeah he's he's screaming at snakes on a plane
maybe they'll get let me say the f word this show
my mother flipping earth yeah no i mean i agree
with you and um i mean we'll see what happens i
know the the show's gotta like you know tell a
story line with the scrolls and all that stuff
but i'm curious to see if they're gonna go
a little bit non-linear storytelling which
show like where he was up in space like what
he was doing how long the passage of time is
yeah i'd be really intrigued to see if they
do show that because i'd love to see that
yeah all right guys what do you think about the
secret invasion trailer i thought it was pretty
awesome we got a world with my night one that
we gotta check out and uh but other than that
thank you guys for being here thank you guys all
right well subscribe click that bell leave a like
brian perry oh my god brian looking up you on
urban dictionary here's what we got let's do
it you're one of the chillest guys you will ever
meet dude let's smoke a fatty together because i
i i do all day every day i always have it never
will stop um it's my reputations you're chill
everybody loves being around brian why because
he's everyone's favorite and he knows it i brian
brian's a bit of a cocky guy i love being around
you right now he's very confident in everything he
does like pledging he's hilarious tell us a joke
will laugh because you tell it with confidence
might not be funny but you're confident like
daniel the cook and has the most beautiful
eyes you've ever seen that's true i looked you up
on social media and i just pissed myself that's
why i have a hard time finding love it's my
natural secretion whatever i see i'm struck
i just have to secrete i have to be spending time
with o'brien is priceless i'm sure we can afford
you the cherry on top is that he is a sex girl
oh wow wow romp between the sheets my god leave
you sore and in a spell for days i want that brian
perry after i want to not be able to walk again i
secrete this here so there's peeing everywhere
and the other side as well yeah you know
well and vomit you might as well
make it it's hard for me to walk bruh
it's the luck of the draw these are all facts of
your name this is what it says yeah and i hope you
live up to it because that is some high stakes
right there you you could easily disappoint if
someone was like i'm going on a date with a guy
named brian let's see what brian's are like my god
hilarious confident and right between the sheets
and this day yeah it's gonna be a life changing a
lot to live up to man go all the way with brian
geez good for you i'm happy for you well done